hey what's going on in still burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on you and your
cubicle do you like that it's in the
corner and you get some Sun I like it it
makes me feel like I'm outside do you
know what I mean do you remember when
you had recess and you just ran you just
had the wind was in your hair that's
what it feels like except them inside
and my dreams have died what's going on
guys my voice is [ __ ] up and it's
Wednesday night I just got out of the
writers room episode 8 [ __ ]
doing the table League [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] do these [ __ ] things come from
cages [ __ ] christ
[ __ ] maas [ __ ] house do you know
they [ __ ] another day my god damn I get
a [ __ ] decent gate for the driveway
for once you know you got to get the
electrical one you know what's great
about the electrical one is eventually
it [ __ ] breaks and you can't get your
car out of there and you got to call a
taxi when you're paying insurance on two
[ __ ] cars although they're right
there you just can't get to them isn't
technology wonderful it makes your life
so much more simple you know you don't
have to get out of a car anymore to open
a gate you don't burn those calories and
then those calories just sit right on
your [ __ ] heart right and then one
day one day the gate doesn't open and
you have a [ __ ] aneurysm because
you're so upset because it was supposed
to make your life easier and it doesn't
my actually have a [ __ ] theory I
don't have a theory I have a [ __ ]
idea that just popped into my head we
should all die it like thirty of natural
[ __ ] causes you know we should just
go back to living off the [ __ ] land
once just the whole plague just hits
everybody we should just you know go
back to being [ __ ] cave people and
live them like you know just living like
30 [ __ ] yeah you can't go that far
back would be a good place to go back to
you know what I mean well anybody in
this era would suck because then there'd
be a bunch of [ __ ] be like what there's
no iPads or polio vaccines man what the
[ __ ] this sucks right
you know no it's not a theory it was
just a [ __ ] idea I mean this is how
Trump gives his speech isn't it is he
going down is that what's happening this
[ __ ] guy just took everybody until
this [ __ ] moment now for the life of
me I do not understand how this this is
my [ __ ] Republican choice I got this
[ __ ] dope or this [ __ ]
square-headed goddamn criminal what is
Hillary Clinton have like what fifty two
felonies pending I think I saw her on
the first forty eight the other night
and now they're just going to just blow
past all of this and then you get up
listen to all this [ __ ] horseshit
about you know how great it is for
[ __ ] women well it's only fair after
all the dishonest guys they've got in
office why don't we get the most crooked
[ __ ] broad we can find you know don't
pick the honest one Wow Jesus I'm in a
grumpy [ __ ] mood there's so much [ __ ]
that I want to say but I can't say it I
just can't [ __ ] say it because it
would be a waste to say it right here
but I am buying my time biting or is it
buying the Joe Biden how to [ __ ] these I
know I'm with hobbies but as well as
expressions that's every time I hear
somebody say debarred it's like they say
buying or biding my time
does it just tell you another thing that
one of my relatives mispronounced and I
just started saying it that way like my
[ __ ] one of my relatives could not
say orange to say orange one an orange
so you know like [ __ ] go to school
what colors that I'm like orange and
people looking like what did you say
orange they're going it's orange so I
you know I didn't know people around my
lips say orange the [ __ ] was I talking
about biding my time is that a word
that's something biding my time or
that's the pink floyd's on biting time
biding my time can you believe that
something on Wikipedia about that well
there's people like you in the world
bill so there needs to be biding my time
was an unreleased recording is it an
expression
what you guys are hearing right now is
how I use the [ __ ] current of the
computer I just ask it I talk to it like
you can hear well can hear me because
he's [ __ ] I'll say [ __ ] to my wife
and all of a sudden you know I'll be
like you know the [ __ ] is your problem
well you know you treat me like a
douchebag right now also I go to my
computer on the side there's all these
advertising for douchebags and I never
looked it up binding my time instead of
biding my time to bide in the binding
ones time is a verb that according to
the American Heritage Dictionary means
to await or wait for people who are in
the language to that level going to the
American Heritage Dictionary somebody
[ __ ] sat down and look that up its
Wikipedia why wouldn't you just make it
up this podcast by the way is brought to
you by Coors Light it's cold lager cold
filtered and cold packaged and you know
what when I'm pitching [ __ ] jokes all
day long in a [ __ ] writers room I
like to come home do a podcast and drink
one can of [ __ ] Coors Light you know
why because it's [ __ ] delicious it's
perfect I don't want to get hammered it
sort of tastes like water but I have a
nice happy feeling afterwards this is me
not drinking is every two days I have
one beer one you know nobody in England
whatever Europe in general would
consider this a [ __ ] beer by the way
Belgium is back on the [ __ ] map that
back on the map we were trying to go to
Germany in Austria but they offered me
like $30 and fifty over maybe it was
euros I can't remember what so I don't
know what the [ __ ] I got going on over
there I got to start trashing their
sports teams so they know who the [ __ ] I
am and maybe they'll watch a few videos
and I can maybe I don't play whatever
version of what's funny boom yeah go
till [ __ ] funny bond all right let's get
back to the [ __ ] podcast what
happened today in the world I have no
[ __ ] idea I said the [ __ ] writers
from all goddamn day
let's see Google News Google News all
right in the US a comprehensive
up-to-date coverage aggregated all right
sit and spin fit in Spurs late my clash
oh this is about the gun [ __ ]
daily trail asian stocks wobble ahead of
somebody cares about that somebody has
so much [ __ ] money that that's going
to gives up [ __ ] what's going on with
that stock you know once we became this
giant financial [ __ ] gang bang it's
just over alligator that snatched
two-year-old boy Disneyworld has been
killed how the [ __ ] did they find it it
didn't eat them there was no evidence of
the kid at him right
somebody rat him out some other [ __ ]
alligator man it wasn't me I I you know
somebody was talking the [ __ ]
alligator probably snatched the kid was
like Jesus Christ it's the [ __ ] kid
thought it was a turtle I don't want to
get [ __ ] sue I'm they're going to
kill me all the animals they got to know
it at this point that if you [ __ ] if
you even [ __ ] with this human being we
come down and we track it down you know
we've done it two alligators we've done
it two sharks who done it two gorillas
that [ __ ] alligator the second he
[ __ ] saw a shirt was just like that's
not a turtle right spit the kid out and
then [ __ ] it took off and it still
wasn't enough we come back around like
bed bug Eddie and [ __ ] nuh [ __ ]
Pope of Greenwich Village to Elias not
three blonde II some Irish [ __ ]
alligator I don't owe him [ __ ]
Coast Guard crews find body and search
for missing father three teens oh my god
people are out of their [ __ ] minds
people go out on boats you know what I
mean stay on a lake a lake is is brutal
enough just cuz the creepy thing a lake
is usually so [ __ ] cold it never
gives up your body you just stay down
there you know it doesn't get warm
enough for the gases in your gut to
[ __ ] make you be a [ __ ] floater
you know what I learned that reading
that book the Westies that one I used to
make people do the Houdini as they say
you know they kill people then they
would chop them up did big [ __ ] thing
was you had to had to you had to gut
them you know because if you didn't you
know whatever happens whatever happens
when you die
you know there's probiotics for the good
bacteria and you got them as a bad
bacteria that bad bacteria that exists
in your gut your whole [ __ ] life sits
there waiting for you to die and when
you die it activates and that's what
[ __ ] makes you decompose according to
the person two stools down for me at a
diner one time right maybe I saw it on
the [ __ ] Internet I have no [ __ ]
idea on my way to a slap fight or some
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] I was going to
watch by the way on Twitter I got
another good one okay WorldStarHipHop
you gotta follow those guys and then
there's 30 second fights
[ __ ] unbelievable why should I back a
car over a woman today
she was [ __ ] up his car right you
know you know women when women flee you
know flip out whatever the [ __ ] you did
cheated on him or whatever they [ __ ] up
your property because they're not going
to get arrested for it because they have
a [ __ ] clan right so this [ __ ]
Chiefs throwing [ __ ] at the guy and the
guys trying to drive away she throws
like three or four [ __ ] things at him
I don't know what it was and finally she
throws his last [ __ ] thing at the guy
and the guy just stops and starts
backing up towards her and I'm thinking
he he's just going to scare he's going
to bump her you know what I mean give
her the old [ __ ] you know those
bumpers you know most of them made out
of [ __ ] flexible plastic figure
worst-case scenario she's going to get a
joke Iseman this [ __ ] guy bumped her
and then just stomped on the gas and
[ __ ] backed all the way over and
continued to go and then [ __ ] him and he
was what kills me I was just I was like
oh my god I thought she was dead dude
she got up it was like a cartoon like I
thought that [ __ ] only happened in a
cartoon I would think once you go
underneath a [ __ ] car that was going
as fast as this [ __ ] guy I mean he's
got to think that the rear axle
you got the differential right there
she's getting a
they have Fred with the [ __ ]
differential forget about the tires how
the car is hot all of that [ __ ] how it
didn't drag her down the [ __ ] Street
it's one of the most brutal things I've
ever seen
having said that they're not all like
that there's a lot of good flight tell
me if you like watching fights like I do
I enjoy watching you know I like
violence I like watching it I don't know
why I liked watching animals attack each
other I like people fighting each other
it's enjoyable to me but I also like you
know I like playing horseshoes
I like that uh what do you recall recall
that [ __ ]
I made a reference to it my life special
for the slide on the ice with that giant
like obese hockey puck with that as a
handle on curling I like that too I can
watch that white dude with the afro do
the paintings on Netflix you know I'm
going to put a happy tree right over
there that what you're going to do I go
ahead and do that [ __ ] I can watch the
700 club I mean do a lot of [ __ ] but I
at the end of there I still enjoy the
violence all right Las Vegas awarded an
NHL franchise oh [ __ ] Jesus Christ what
are they thinking were they trying to
become the NBA that yeah okay right now
do you think the [ __ ] NBA sticks now
wait to the Vegas gets a [ __ ] team
Kevin Durant signing with Golden State
Warriors warriors would be mutually
beneficial Touhou warrior fans Steven
Tyler says the Aerosmith train won't
keep a rolling after next tour is the
end near Jesus Christ everyone is more
intense
mucks calls Tesla's SolarCity deal
no-brainer investors disagree dude how
is this Tesla guy man this guy's just
he's [ __ ] with he's [ __ ] with some
old money so the guy who makes the Tesla
car by the way you guys like Jaguars
I like their entry level one the [ __ ]
you get the top of the line sports model
one you get it in that [ __ ] British
racing green I just wish you could get
it in a stick every con has got a
[ __ ] it's basically their free Series
you know
which is really you know if you give a
[ __ ] should be the highest series that
you buy because some douche is going to
come in and sideswipe you you're lucky
maybe they'll even know alright let's
see what this guys doing
Ellen musk inhabits a world of
declarative superlatives
well whatever world that is I don't know
what in those words mean declarative
superlatives he lives in that world well
no wonder you figured out I got a lick
of cargo that [ __ ] fast he lives in a
world of declarative superlattice Jesus
Christ there's a whole other [ __ ]
group of people I've never met
honey earned their [ __ ] all over the
place and [ __ ] walking into gorilla
enclosures on a conference call with
investors early Wednesday Tesla CEO call
this companies 2.8 billion dollar offer
for a solar city a no-brainer that is
legally and morally correct a zero doubt
move that we shouldn't have done sooner
I agree with all of this I don't know
how much it should cost though what's
more must trumpet trumpeted that the
deal could help propel Tesla toward the
world's first trillion dollar company as
the solution to the Earth's climate
change problem Jesus did Trump write
this analysis aren't so sure well who
are the [ __ ] analysis getting paid by
the big oil companies at a steep drop in
Tesla stock down 10% in Wednesday's
trading wacking 3 billion off its lofty
32 billion dollar market cap confirms
investor skepticism [ __ ] you you just
don't want to see him do it why can't
the government give them some money the
way they did the bank's [ __ ] Solar
City man you make weed legal right you
grow it under solar panels every morning
everybody you know there's like a
continental breakfast right you get eggs
from chickens it's to live their beaks
and they're not on roids like Mark
McGwire right they got that little
[ __ ] waffle flippy thing you pour it
in and you turn it over you know
somebody sent me something today where
actually some scientists which I'm sure
he's underground and he has no corporate
money
behind them described humanity the way
every great comic I've ever seen has
starting with [ __ ] Bill Hicks that
basically said that human beings are a
plague number one time reading a Joe
Rogan blog and he was take [ __ ] said
he was flying over the US and he was
looking down and just seeing how
beautiful the country was and he was
just looking at all the cities though as
she went through and how dirty and
filthy or he said we're like a fungus
you know what I mean and I if you could
interview fungus or whatever a virus out
there they could kill us if you could
talk to them you know they don't think
they're bad people you know they don't
have that perspective because they're
just hanging around with other viruses
or people of the same virus you know
what I mean like if you could interview
with chicken and ask it what it thinks
the human beings you wouldn't want to
see remember the last episode of
Seinfeld when everybody came back and
talked about what selfish pieces of [ __ ]
Elaine Jerry [ __ ] Diane whatever the
[ __ ] to any Kramer was the other guy's
name Eddie
anyway save day with the otago pieces of
[ __ ] they where you have chickens
dolphins anybody poisonous snakes Tigers
all of them they could just sit down and
talk about it say yeah they wouldn't
like us I mean they keep man you know
what they go back to all the Quran they
go out to the [ __ ] Bible the Torah
all our religious books and just be like
yeah they read this thing and then they
think it's okay to [ __ ] do a bunch of
[ __ ] to us because some fat guy named
Buddha said it was okay you know what do
you guys think like the right population
number should be you know and how would
you get the number down at this point I
mean drastic [ __ ] magic you know they
got to put something in the [ __ ]
water to just sterilize people and just
act like it was a mistake just have
Monsanto do it you can't [ __ ] sue him
it's illegal right whatever the [ __ ] it
is
whatever Obama signed the great liberal
[ __ ] president that he was signed
that [ __ ] thing that said you know
they didn't have to say that their food
was genetically altered yeah what a
patriot
all these [ __ ] [ __ ] they're all the
same don't go go go do your [ __ ]
speeches for five on a grander whack
don't do that don't give your kid a
[ __ ] zillion dollar wedding you don't
give a [ __ ] right so the city yeah na
what do you say yea or nay what do you
say I say go ahead and [ __ ] do it
that's what you should do you know it
would be great about a solar city then
we don't need the people's [ __ ] oil in
the Middle East and then they gradually
just go bankrupt you know there's no
money flying around there then they
don't have any money for a [ __ ]
nuclear warhead and then everybody just
relaxes they go back to doing their [ __ ]
we go back to doing our [ __ ] the reality
is is in both parts of the world most
people are just minding their own
[ __ ] business
it's the [ __ ] up at the top that hang
out with Hillary at the Bilderberg
meetings that they're the ones that just
can't stand the fact that this [ __ ]
people living somewhere and then I'm
making any money off of them oh Jesus
who had a Twitter a third of a Coors
Light in his [ __ ] saying things he's
not reading things people he spoiled but
he's saying things let's go over to
sports
this is a typical [ __ ] sports story
now rape survivor finally faces
nebraska's Riley - what I'm trying to
I'm trying to get away from this [ __ ]
this belongs on the [ __ ] sports page
looks like they have a rape section
doing that right up to the other metro
region all right mm-hmm
where is the sports Jon Jones says
hatred for Daniel Cormier is fading no
date is set for Tiger Woods return he's
got to win another one he's got to win
one more after four decades wait manager
great for a grateful for a job this is
what it's like this ranking NBA's worst
number one drastic since 1989 of course
they got Greg Oden there so what they
should just show with everybody the
Portland Trailblazers drafted over the
last 30 [ __ ] years oh [ __ ]
but again oh man I think I'll stay on
this website I wasn't going to stay I've
also in ball ball chicken coop on Padang
total Depot blow up a dead do but dagger
didn't did skip skip bayless gives
emotional goodbye to first take in
Steven a Smith oh thank god he's leaving
what's he going to get into he should go
work with Joel Olsteen he should open
for him
the two-headed monster well everything
that both of them say is equally not
believable
all right the Philadelphia 76ers they
drafted a guy Andrea barn game well he's
mean he's got a [ __ ] woman's name
this is men's basketball
Pervis Ellison Sacramento Kings Ford
lasted one season in Sacramento before
he's dealt to Washington when they was
still called the bullets where he logged
two great years that was about it well
you know if injuries injuries that I'll
give a [ __ ] about injuries it's when
you're helping you still suck Joe Smith
said a [ __ ] alias the funny thing
about Smith's is his career lasted a
long time
alright I don't know any of these people
are Michael Ola Wonka donkey Kwame Brown
Greg Oden I like Greg his hot you know
he was an old soul he looked like Bill
Russell does now except he's Grecian
formula and he came into the league he
didn't we wanted to earn his [ __ ]
money Anthony Bennett number one the
Cleveland Cavaliers this would be
something you know it's great keep
Cavalier fans and now you can [ __ ]
laugh about it right did I talk about
you guys yet no because I talked it
before the [ __ ] game congratulations
I cannot [ __ ] believe how happy I was
when the Cavaliers won we were working
in a Baltimore Baltimore and I watched
what's like the first quarter then I
went on stage when I got off thank God
it was the NBA there was still like
[ __ ] three quarters left now it was
like five minutes left ten
left I can't [ __ ] remember I watched
most of the fourth quarter right which
would be like 10 minutes and I can't
remember what the [ __ ] had happened that
guy hit the three Joe Barry Carol hit
that [ __ ] three and I live he was
watching watching watching thinking you
know I knew I wanted Cleveland when he
[ __ ] hit that thing dude I just stood
up just like I was almost like when the
Bruins won the Stanley Cup and all of a
sudden there was just like five minutes
left they were controlling the play and
you just could feel it I just stood up
and I yelled dick got it so it they got
to do it of course she's going don't
jinx him I'm like I had my own [ __ ]
have any control over this [ __ ] and then
when the guy who punches everybody in
the balls who you can't stand but you
would love if he was on your team he
fought when he filed LeBron I thought
LeBron landed on his wrist I thought he
broke his shooting hand I was like oh my
god he did down by there up by three
he's going to miss them both he's going
to be out of the [ __ ] game and then
the honors honor roll students going to
come down hit a [ __ ] three do one of
those Skippy [ __ ] dances you know
that makes you want to give him a leg
sweet right they're going to tie it up
going the all the time they're going to
[ __ ] and they're going to lose it
and he misses the first one and I knew
he's going to hit the next one he seems
alright he's got to [ __ ] hit it BAM
he hits it that was great I got to tell
you a little bit too much crying for me
though I didn't mind LeBron crying but I
don't know what the [ __ ] that that
guy in that suit on your bench I didn't
see much of you know because you know
LeBron coaches the [ __ ] team what's
his name Lou I mean that guy that guy
was like bawling I can understand LeBron
there was just a lot of crying I was
trying to picture Pat like the Lakers
winning it Magic Johnson crying like
that and then [ __ ] LeBron dummy
LeBron [ __ ] Pat Pat Riley also crying
like that bent over and like his hair
comes down you know because the mousse
isn't holding it anymore you know it's a
different time this is what happens when
you put dr. Phil on for [ __ ] 20 years
you know you just keep backing guys into
the can open up open up open up well
ladies there you go is that what you
wanted to see a bunch of people fall
into their knees and you know started at
Chris Bosh started it I actually
respected the fact that he did it you
know he just got it I lost the [ __ ]
championship he was sad he just [ __ ]
cried let me read a little bit of
advertising here just a little bit Oh
Club Gabby Gabby had been on the
Warriors Club W delivers wine straight
to your door we send you wine that is
personalized to your pal by the way I
had a [ __ ] bed with Rappaport I still
haven't heard from the man still haven't
heard from still not as still I [ __ ]
called the final game of that Warriors
game you know the spread was seven I
said give me eight and that was the
exact [ __ ] number now what do we do
double or nothing I said two Cavaliers
and seven you know I have not heard from
that man
so you [ __ ] Michael Rappaport's the
real Rappaport whatever he's calling
himself right now the notorious Michael
Rapaport you let that man know that
there's another man on another [ __ ]
podcast who also doesn't know what the
[ __ ] he's talking about and he's looking
for okay because that son of a [ __ ]
owes me a steak dinner alright anyways
club Danny Club Gabby high-class steak I
stole a bunch of gold bars from my last
day in office delivers wine straight to
your door we send you wine and it's
personalized to your palate taste
through our palate quiz our
recommendations become even more
personalized with every bottle you rate
so the more you booze the more we know
about you we work with top winemakers
and growers from around the world
directly to make all of our own wine our
$13 bottles would normally retail for
$20 you choose the type in the quantity
of bottles and no membership fee or
cancellation fee and 100% satisfaction
guarantee
we partner with local artists to develop
wine labels that are unique works of art
that's actually cool how to get your
complimentary wine please visit
[Music]
email sent to you by Charles and aux
Oxford Road comm apply the promo code at
checkout all right I know what that
means that sounds like I'm not getting
any credit maybe they're sick and we
going Club Debbie clean Debbie I used to
booze now I speak Spanish
all right bowline branch everybody as
you set out to improve yourself there is
one simple thing you can do every day to
help you be your best in every situation
and that is getting a good night's sleep
bowl and branch delivers the rest now
the [ __ ] moth bowl and branch
delivers the rest you need wrapped up in
their super comfortable luxury linens
and they do it right there the first
bedding company to be Fairtrade
certified which means that your sheets
come from the work happy oh come from
the work of happy hands not sweatshop
hands and beautiful packaging made
entirely from recyclable recycled
sustainable materials next please
mention that I'm going to mention it you
can only get these sheets in one place
that's Bowl and branch comm where you
know you're paying for quality and not
the department store overhead you're
getting thousand dollar sheets for just
a couple hundred bucks go online to bold
branch that's bol el and branch calm and
they'll let you try them risk-free for
30 nights if you don't love them you can
send them back row you have nothing to
lose and it gets even better go to bull
branch calm today for 20% off your
entire order sheets towels blankets
duvet covers everything plus free
shipping and all their products come
beautifully packaged in the signature
boxes boxes go to Boland branch calm
today whole needy off day that's when
you get 20% off your entire order and
use the promo code BER it's bold
bol el and branch pran CH like cliff
comm promo code Burke Bowl and brain
Stockholm Bowman Cooper alright two more
two more hanging the hanging that track
or snot cash might fall of smart homes
technology has made everything wicked
smaht but losing your stuff still makes
mad people feel really [ __ ] stupid
tracker makes losing things the thing in
the past kid hey skipper listen to this
that track is a coin side device that
locates misplaced keys wallets bags
computers anything in seconds the
[ __ ] 12-pack where did it go BP
people there it is let's get [ __ ]
hammered kid just pay a tracker to your
[ __ ] smartphone attach it to anything
and find its precise location with the
tap of the button where's my weed dude
not a problem it's right over there
let's [ __ ] burn one before we go to
work dude it's that easy lose your
[ __ ] phone no problem press the
[ __ ] track a button are you catching
on yet you [ __ ] stick it on [ __ ] that
you lose and when you lose it you hit a
[ __ ] button with over 1.5 million
devices tracking has the largest crowd
GPS network in the world so you lost
[ __ ] items show up on a map even if
it's [ __ ] miles away kid how [ __ ]
up is that
you want another Bud Light not buy it
never lose anything again with tracker
listen to this show get a special
discount a 30% off your entire [ __ ]
order go to be spelt ehe what do you
[ __ ] still put it something
Temptation th e track accom and then the
promo code barbie you are the hottest
thing you'll ever have to finance their
[ __ ] website go to track accom right
now and enter the promo code bar for 30%
off your entire [ __ ] order again
that's tracking comp form of code bro
you [ __ ] [ __ ] alright last but
not least zip the cooler are you hiring
you know where to post your job to find
the best candidates posting your job in
one place isn't enough to find quality
candidates if you want to find the
perfect hire you need to post your job
on all the job sites and now you can
with zip rip product calm sorry you can
post your job to 100 plus job sites
including social media networks like
Facebook Twitter and with all with one
single click find candidates in any city
or industry nationwide just post once
and watch all your qualified candidates
roll into zip regret easy-to-use
interface no juggling emails call to
your call to your office ringing out of
[ __ ] quickly screen candidates rate
them and hire them how the right person
fast find out today why is it recruit
has been used by over 800,000 businesses
and right now listeners can try zip
recruit it for free by going to zip
recruited comm / / that zip recruited
comm / / one more time it goes it's free
go to zip recruiter dot-com / / all
right there we go I think that's the
podcast here that's the podcast that's
the podcast I hope you [ __ ] enjoy it
the weekends coming up everybody bump
bump bump bump get into baseball with
and Wimbledon coming up all you sports
fans out there you know what I mean when
you're not reading about a rape case you
know when you want to watch a game you
don't wind up reminded that people are
dying to cancer or you know whatever
[ __ ] another other miserable
[ __ ] thing they just got to
bring up with sports all the goddamn
time now you know what it is is
everybody's watching sports now nobody's
watching the news so now they got to try
to jam all the news they got to jam the
news a [ __ ] telethon you know just any
[ __ ] goddamn thing going on you know
yeah there's an outbreak of the mumps
and next thing you know they're going to
parade a bunch of kids out with swollen
faces how about a moment of silence
you know everybody pop out their cheeks
in silence i watch sports to get away
from that [ __ ] okay I [ __ ] hate
people they're a bunch of and i know i
hate groups i don't undermine
individuals okay with an individual i
can see the [ __ ] light but i don't
need to be reminded
okay i'm trying to get away from that
[ __ ] [ __ ] and i don't know where to
go you're going to take sports from me i
don't know what to tell you but you know
what that's a topic for another [ __ ]
podcast alright have a great weekend you
[ __ ] good luck to you and all your
future [ __ ] decision making and and
that's it does a little bit of music
here and
you'll enjoy hopefully you'll enjoy some
go back [ __ ] clips from the podcast
but another time my body likes top down
in the doors I try to shoot a thought
when watch cause I'm gonna do some
scratch words in the dirt and watch the
water roll down and I'm just rather like
an insect be slides up and down on the
right check my candle and I'll be down
to Sarah's mother I watch the water
rolls out may the love Jones and John
and Marianna hey what's going on
so far it's the Monday morning podcast
and before I get started with the
podcast I want to thank all of you who
watched me last night on the Sahel was
it the guys Choice Awards on Spike
I don't know what happened I did six
minutes to stand up evidently they cut
it down to two minutes maybe it's
because I'm dangerous I don't know what
but uh I probably should have told
people to TiVo it I don't know I guess
some people might have been I don't know
I didn't say I was hosting it you know
what I mean some people are upset by how
you know like do with the [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] you [ __ ] it hour and a half and
you only on for [ __ ] two minutes well
guess what
I didn't direct it all right I don't
edit it if I did it would have been two
hours of me it would have been it would
have been the Goldberg Tyler Perry
presents bilborough's [ __ ] guys
Choice Awards and it would have been two
hours of me
you know actually you know what I do a
little bit of stand-up and so I do a
little bit of stand-up again standing
ovations and then Oprah would suddenly
appear on like this motorized couch
I guess sofa and she just sort of be
brought to the front of the stage and as
I was putting the Mike in the Mike
Spencer will just be seamless like we
wouldn't even have commercials and then
I would sit down and she would just
start interviewing me with like some
sort of you know turtleneck sweater on
you know and you know just ask me how I
out how is it that I became so amazing
you know so picture that now what do you
think would be worse what the [ __ ] you
saw last night or that horrific image I
just brought up anyways this is the
Monday morning podcast I do one of these
every week and that's a truck-driving
vibes you can hear that Jesus Christ I
do one of these every week [ __ ] for
25 minutes or so and I answer questions
that people might have and a lot of
times I ask questions and then people
give me answers like last week I didn't
know the difference between effect and
effect and somebody sent me [ __ ] two
paragraphs which was annoying you know I
want a definition okay in my world a
definition is one sentence to number you
know and then they write the [ __ ]
definition and then maybe there's a
number two or number three but I never
[ __ ] read those so I'll try to
abbreviate these the word effect with an
a as an [ __ ] is primarily used as a
verb in English oh okay good because I
want to make sure I don't [ __ ] it up
when I'm speaking Latin later on today
anyways it has two main meanings which
are closely related effect may mean to
alter the feelings of or to change the
mental state of someone or something may
also mean in a purse sense to change or
affect someone or something in any way
see I still don't know what that means
this is why I'm a comedian because I you
know I I sucked in school it may also
mean in a broader sense to change or
affect someone or something in any way
that doesn't even mean anything the word
East [ __ ] it let's move on to effect
maybe if I know what effect is I know
the definition of that thing that when
the word doesn't fit into the definition
of that I'll know it's [ __ ] aspect
effect and contrast when contrast is use
primarily as a noun in English as a
number of related meanings and you know
what I just realized I don't give a [ __ ]
and right there people you realize why I
got an 8/10 combined on my SATs I don't
know what part of the country you're
from but in my my neck of the woods a
1600 was a perfect score and I believe
you got a good 300 points just for
signing his [ __ ] name and I got an
8/10 combined and I'd love to sit there
and tell you that I didn't try and then
I was like man it's all [ __ ] [ __ ]
government with the test man I wasn't
like that I tried with all my might and
all my concentration I actually was
doing me like even ones that I didn't
know the answer to which evidently was
more than 70% of the [ __ ] test I
would try to do the process elimination
and you know you think Jesus Christ I
could guess Thank You Thomas it was
definitely you know it wasn't even
devastating none of it was devastating
because of my great mindset that I had
in high school which was basically I
don't give a [ __ ] that was uh that's
been my mindset for a long time and
forty years old and I'm paying the price
for it
alright anyways um this is what's going
on in my life this uh this week alright
this is really becoming a codependent
thing here I keep asking you guys to
help members back in the day when you
guys ask me questions and I answer them
down [ __ ] asking you questions and I
have actually haven't answered any
goddamn questions in a couple weeks so
why don't I go to that that's what I'm
going to do going to go to the questions
okay let's read a couple here then I'll
get to my [ __ ] questions for you guys
and this is going to be a blue collar
question alright so if you clicking away
on a spreadsheet you can just tune out
in about ten minutes but anyways here
the questions hey Bill when you go to a
baseball game do you prefer a night game
or a day game well considering
um I'm [ __ ] pasty I definitely prefer
the I definitely prefer the night game
yeah yeah because I don't want to get a
sunburn and then also getting shit-faced
during the day it's really a depressing
thing past a certain age you know you do
it at night it's no big deal you know
you get shit-faced at night you come
home and you pass out and you wake up
and there's about ten seconds of what
the [ __ ] that I do that for before the
phone rings and your day starts and you
don't really have time to contemplate
what a [ __ ] loser you are but when
you get shit-faced during the day at a
[ __ ] baseball game aside from the
fact that you know the odds of you
scaring children are increased by eighty
percent when you go to a day game and
get hammered yeah then you [ __ ] go
home and it's like I don't know you get
home at like 6:00 and you just drunk you
know maybe it pass out for like till
like 8:00 and then you wake up and
[ __ ] the TV's on way too loud
somebody screaming about Dancing with
the Stars you know then you can't fall
asleep again till 1:00 in the morning so
then you order a [ __ ] pizza and it's
just it's just a vicious circle start
thinking things like man what if I just
ran headfirst into that bookcase maybe I
could just knock myself out and I
wouldn't have to sit here smelling like
draft beer with the third-degree burns
on my forehead yeah so there you go
I uh I prefer to go to the night games
what the day games they always have
those [ __ ] stupid giveaways first two
hundred people its backpack day
you know a bad day you know it's great
they even got rid of that day because
that they thought it was too violent
and what's so [ __ ] but you know this
is what kills me was back in the day
when they had that day you went down
there and you got a full slot full-size
full-size full-size but he's fall back
goddamn Louisville Slugger you got a
full-size [ __ ] fetch it was
ridiculous you know and all they talk
about [ __ ] global warming and you
know oil and all that crap people trying
to come up with solutions it always
blows my mind that they never talked
about that day how the amount of [ __ ]
trees that they had to chop down to give
away like five thousand bats at every
game around
ramaa god damn god damn like how many
[ __ ] teams were in the league when I
was a kid like 26 26 times 5,000 that
see 2010 it's [ __ ] hundred twenty-five
thousand plus seven others 3000 thousand
[ __ ] bats you know but now listen to
me I got an 8/10 combined on my [ __ ]
SATs and I tried Jesus Christ I tried I
was definite you know and they usually
say you know when you give a hundred
percent you know it's one of the great
things about giving 100 percent is that
you can't you can't feel bad who's
bringing me out Jesus Christ this is my
home phone not to blow this off you know
what you know you know it's calling me
right now I'm going to blow it off I
bought a I bought a set of you know
those gymnastic rings do you guys watch
do you watch the gymnasium devil watch
that [ __ ] how many [ __ ] times is my
phone line before it goes to the gut in
machine evidently 26 you guys ever watch
this is my deal man I'm trying to you
know turn 40 [ __ ] trying to
compensate so I'm trying to find new
ways to get in shape you know I mean how
many times can you get out of the gym
and set throwing the weights around like
your luffa rigna you know plus when you
lift weight you don't necessarily get in
you get in like
a t-shape how many 80s the girls well
like you know trying to dress like
Olivia newton-john doing aerobics you
know no dressing like strippers and then
all the guys everybody everybody
basically in the 80s everybody had a
huge upper body and then they had
pretzel rod legs because nobody did know
we did like so we did squats you know
everybody's old [ __ ] chest and back
well contrite and thighs oh so you know
now you lift weights you just get off
[ __ ] you get all puffy so I was just
sitting there uh I was flipping through
the channels right I'm not gonna lie to
you gymnastics came on it always kind of
blows my mind the level of strengths of
those guys have and I was sitting on the
floor and I was watching somebody they
went into I think it's called the pike
position sounds like [ __ ] you know what
I do sit-ups I thought I could try and
do that and I can't even explain to you
like you ever try to do something and
it's like not only can you not I mean
physically not only can you not do it
your brain it's like you know you have
those muscles so when you go to do it
you actually feel like you're paralyzed
because you're sending this message to
your muscle going okay do this and it's
not even like your muscles going like
you know I I tried but we can't yeah
yeah there's like no response it's like
yelling down a hole it's some [ __ ]
five-year-old who fell down it in the
middle of a white-trash town in Arkansas
I don't know let's get let's get that
contract so I bought these uh they're
called elite rings and you [ __ ] you
tied to your chin up bar and you know
basically you work your way up one day
you're doing an Iron Cross right in the
middle of your living room is you're
watching the [ __ ] Evening News that's
what I'm working towards okay so I get
these goddamn rings I'm all excited
right you think I had a kid or something
like this is how [ __ ] excited and
self-centered I am that I get that
excited about something material that I
bought for myself rather than bringing a
new life into the world that I can
you know try to nurture whatever it is
you do as a parent and anyways I got
these things that for the life of me I
can't figure out how to [ __ ] how to
set them up they came they gave me this
really bad videotape with these Russian
guys on it this is this is a denier so
and so here's the 19 the 2005 rings
champion here he is doing an inverted
[ __ ] whatever you know but they never
showed you how to put the goddamn rope
through the [ __ ] rink so that's what
that phone calls evidently going to be
because I called him up early this
morning the 1-800 number and I was like
yes I got the Rings oh yes they're
fantastic but your shitty little DVD
slash snuff film doesn't explain how to
put the [ __ ] rope through the ring
and I own the guys like okay well you
know I don't really have the Rings in
front of me so I can't really tell you
how to do it the and it's like it said
on the [ __ ] invoice but if I had a
problem I could call this number alright
they didn't say I'd be talking to you
you [ __ ] [ __ ] so basically the guy
has United the [ __ ] guy in the 1-800
you know what else would I be calling
them about you know Jesus Christ I got
the invoice that means I got the ring
now what else would I be calling him for
what have you call him up to see if he
could come over and spot me as I do an
inverted headstand
so anyways you've got to have the head
of the company call me or some [ __ ] I
don't know so I blew that off I blew it
off at you guys
you like that giving you a little bit of
guilt alright so if anybody knows how to
string up [ __ ] gymnastic rings for
the love of God if you want to cup
Scouts or something if you can somehow
tell me how to do that so I actually
don't [ __ ] break my neck while doing
this [ __ ] it would be great we
appreciate it
alright let's move on to the next
question
telomeres oh here's one huh anyway bill
I was wondering does your grandmother
still drive yes she does Mike you
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's an inside joke for
people listen to the Opie and Anthony
show okay
next podcast question what will be the
moment that makes you decide to stop
doing these podcasts I am one of the
loyal 14 listeners as you always say I
love hearing them blah blah blah so if
you keep them coming every week
b-52's what will be the moment that
makes me stop doing them
I don't know I'm rubbing my forehead
right now with my eyes closed
trying to think of an answer I don't
know if I actually was I probably would
have stopped doing them a while ago but
I have a need to be liked and if I stop
doing them it would only take one email
from just one person going like I can't
believe you stopped doing them I know I
really enjoyed them you know I've been
going through some difficult times
lately last summer I was trying to make
some lemonade and when I went to put it
into the picture it shattered and the
glass came up and it hit me in my eye
and I haven't been able to work and I
been home and we used to look forward to
the bloody mony punctures and as
ridiculous as that [ __ ] jobs actually
get stories like that so what actually I
don't get stories like that I get more
serious ones and but they're not funny
so I decided to make up that one about
the [ __ ] pitcher of lemonade which
really wasn't that funny
but you know you try you throw it out
there what else we got here I thought he
had more [ __ ] questions than that
you know it is I [ __ ] take these
questions and I copy and paste them and
they just somehow they never end up like
three in a row baseball game your
grandmother
oh there's one okay so what did you take
on this next election who do you think
has a shot at the throne
and are you pissed how much hype it's
getting I don't know that's how I
entered idk yeah I can't believe how
much hype be who's going to be the next
president of the United States is
getting what the [ __ ] was it yeah it's
always annoying when things that don't
deserve to be Heights like you know
landing on the moon and the next
presidential election are getting you
know I wish they would continue focusing
on other things that are more important
like the next American Idol who's left
in the Big Brother house and I don't
know when the next episode of [ __ ]
mind of Mencia is out I don't you know
no I'm not pissed at uh
I get me honest with you I haven't even
been watching it because I get so
goddamn depressed that they never really
talk about anything and no matter what
you ask them you'd be like you know hey
what do you do about the troops in Iraq
and then I'll just be like you know the
troops in Iraq is an issue that
everybody's very concerned about and
it's something that definitely needs to
be addressed and when the time is right
we are going to sit down with some
people who are very knowledgeable in
that field and we are going to have an
assessment and after doing some sort of
research we will arrive at a a
conclusion that we will be presenting
next question and that that's it just
becomes that guru I think has a shot at
the throne well I mean I spend a lot of
time in New York in LA so obviously I
would think that Barack is going to win
by a landslide but when I go on the road
and I get to some of these other states
like North Carolina in Georgia you know
when you walk down the street for some
reason the music in your head
which is from Jack Johnson just a good
old boy never mean in the Hall meets all
year so been in trouble with the nulls
and the state it was born
you think John McCain's gonna win
personally I don't want a president who
can't do the wave
okay that's alright that's one of the
most evil [ __ ] things I have set so
those you don't realize John McCain
can't lift his arms tap the shoulders
because he was tortured in captivity
while fighting for freedom for myself to
do this podcast at least that's a was
that's the way they would frame it on
Fox News you know rather than it was
picked at his dad he was trying to outdo
him and he got a jet and he could have
bailed out or flew away but he didn't
and you know I'm saying what the [ __ ] I
would never give people about my podcast
I'm not doing this podcast for your
freedom anyways what do I think is going
to win I have no [ __ ] idea
I do like John McCain I like John McCain
because the [ __ ] right-wing psychos
don't like him and I don't consider Bush
and Dick Cheney to be Republicans I
consider them to be psychos who call
themselves Republicans I don't think
Republicans are as bad as Bush and
Cheney I really don't I think they were
an oil guy and a guy worked at General
Electric at Halliburton we let the nuts
run the [ __ ] asylum and now we're
paying for it so either way I don't
think either guy's going to be I don't
know I think we I don't know Bhama I
don't even [ __ ] know I like Ron Paul
but I've done this before I always vote
for that [ __ ] guy any and nobody else
does you know you should see my voting
record let's see you want to hear my
voting record a lot of people keep this
[ __ ] private but I don't because I don't
give a [ __ ] alright in 1988 was the
first time I voted for president and I
voted for George Bush Senior over
Michael Dukakis and had nothing to do
with him sticking his head out of that
tank squinting looking like some sort of
a muppet I just voted that way because
that's the way everyone else around me
was building and I was [ __ ] 20 years
old all right
1992 I voted for Ross Perot because uh I
don't know he actually seemed to be
[ __ ] answering questions you know and
the other two weren't you know Bill
Clinton just kept smiling
playing a saxophone you know trying to
be the cool guy it campaign so it
[ __ ] postage just on him leaning
against the wall with his thumbs in his
pocket looking down the hall with one
foot on the floor and the other foot up
against the wall you know that's step
[ __ ] now that was his [ __ ] vibe you
know you know ain't puts on weight like
a [ __ ] - I never liked his mother and
hips and then in 1996 Blas Perot came
back I wasn't feeling him and Bob Dole
seemed like that grumpy guy next door
who calls the cops when you had a keg
party so I went with Bill Clinton and in
2000 I didn't like Bush and I didn't
like Al Gore I didn't like either one of
them so I went with [ __ ] Ralph Nader
and would have [ __ ] as that leader we
didn't let us to the last one I remember
who I voted the last time I didn't vote
for [ __ ] John Kerry and I didn't vote
for John Kerry you know what kills his
campaign for me was when he fasted he
was questioning George Bush for uh you
know during the Vietnam War spending the
war in the stockroom at a CVS before
going home later on that afternoon so he
was trying to you know pipe up his
military career he got behind the podium
O'Neal and Senator Kerry reporting for
duty and it was one of the Kony's things
I've ever seen and he delivered the line
just just in a horrible way you know
worse than Mark Wahlberg in the
happening I don't know if anybody says
anybody seen that [ __ ] movie it's so
bad
it's it almost comes back around to
being good again if movies weren't
[ __ ] $12 or whatever the [ __ ] they
are now you know I don't know just go
the moral of the movie that I got is you
know and this is a spoiler alert spoiler
alert can't even say it just [ __ ]
plug up you goddamn ears here all right
I'm going to talk about it for 15
seconds and then you can turn the sound
back up all right
the morale of the happening was
basically it doesn't make a difference
if you're a scientist or if you sound
dumb jock nobody knows what the [ __ ] is
going on but we better love each one
each other better love each other around
the tree because if we don't the [ __ ]
trees will kill us you know what I
realized my [ __ ] stutter and through
all of that was worse than the goddamn
movie all right I hope you brought the
sound back up okay here we go we're
going to end this podcast with Oh bad
char stories okay and before I go I want
to thank everybody for coming out to the
punchline in Atlanta last week I had a
great time and I want to thank that
woman who when I was ranting about
adopting a dog decided to stand up like
she was in a Coal Miner's Daughter and
read me the riot act about [ __ ] Great
Danes or whatever the hell she was
talking about but anyway thanks for
everybody came out there and I'm going
to be at the The Improv in Pittsburgh
July 10th through the through 13th and I
will be going to the Pirates game and I
will be going to a day game possibly
which means they're probably giving away
its fanny pack day it stuck in Three
Rivers Stadium or whatever you call that
new one that shows that piss yellow
bridge in the background every time the
other team gets a home run okay let's
get to let's get the [ __ ] up car
stories here oh and I'm serious about
those rings by the way I wasn't kidding
if anybody knows how to string those
things up please for the love of God let
me know okay just give people a
backstory if you're new to my podcast
I had a dead my car for three months I
finally got the [ __ ] thing fixed five
days later I took it to I had it valid
and I came downstairs and [ __ ] things
dented and the exact same goddamn spot
and I learned about the expression to be
beside oneself alright so anyways people
wanted to tell me their [ __ ] awful
car stories a lot of anger in these so
if you're not into dirty words you might
want to block here block your ears okay
car stories bill I liked your podcast
and I can relate to the dent story some
very old [ __ ] some very old [ __ ] as
opposed to a you know middle-aged [ __ ]
so our just an old cut some very old
[ __ ] what constitutes a very old [ __ ]
I'm going to say older than 78 and has
been smoking camel on filters since the
30s some very old [ __ ] hit my car after
I had just fixed it was running like
gold it happened a week before Christmas
and the old blind [ __ ] her name was
Emma [ __ ] eating hat country things
happen I never heard that word country
until I'd listened to you okay well
maybe someday I'll teach you how to
finish a [ __ ] story
I guess she just hit it was running like
gold to me just abbreviating having a
week for Christmas the old blind [ __ ]
her name was Emma
Irma alright karma you know I'm always
fascinated with old people's names like
Alma you know I mean you hear the name
Irma you just know it's somebody [ __ ]
old you know or Gladys and the weird
thing is is you know that when they were
being born like those word good new hip
names like you know people will name
their kids like Dakota you know someday
Dakota like later on at the end of this
century Dakota there's an old guy named
Dakota hope is a baby
there's an old lady named [ __ ] Apple
like that name is gonna that's going to
be like Ebenezer that's what happens
that's what happens man you can look it
up alright let's get on with these
[ __ ] things all right y'all bill
what's going on what's going on dude I
have a Lancer Evolution I don't know
what that is I had a dent in it from
getting groceries at Super Walmart as
much as I hate that [ __ ] evil company
they are the cheapest won't do that's
yeah that's how it works it's [ __ ]
huge and they drop the prices and they
put the mom and pops out of business
because idiots like you go to them
rather than sticking it out with the
mom-and-pop and letting the billionaire
with his 9 million square feet to out of
[ __ ] business so as much as yeah yeah
you helping them [ __ ] continue their
their domination oh and then he writes
whatever almost like he knew I was going
to rant about that anyways while I was
in there I got hit in the front of my
car and it dented the [ __ ] out of the
front bumper and busted a headlight of
course I snap and I went back into the
store screaming about this and demanded
to see the parking lot cameras I like
that that's a strong move of course that
week the to far side cameras were not
working and I never found out who did it
three months later after driving around
constantly looking like a total [ __ ]
up loser I got it fixed okay three
months later you get your car fixed and
what happened that night I was driving
in Cleveland Ohio
I live in Modena parentheses [ __ ]
and I come out and I hit a massive
pothole and blew out my tire crack my
bumper and wheel well I called the city
and they just and they said that they
just passed the bill saying that they
were no longer responsible for damage
caused by potholes oh my god he writes
the rage I had at that point I just
wanted to kill as many innocent people
as possible after having getting my car
fixed twice you know what how does that
work within government does anybody
notice know how that works how do they
they pass a bill that they're not
responsible you know what I mean like if
they ever put that on a bill no one no
regular person whatever whatever both to
have that passed I wish I could [ __ ]
do it
no longer responsible for getting drunk
and putting my hands on your person all
right here's the last one I'm going to
wrap up this podcast I like this one
because all the other ones people have
been telling me has been like you know
they didn't do anything and they weren't
at fault like like this guy I've been
without my car for over two weeks now
first I had to take it to the shop
because I had an intake problem I would
think I'd make that [ __ ] up because I
know you don't you have no idea what it
is what's probably well you know what's
problem my car oh you got to take
problem you got a busted aspirator tube
they just picked that obscure [ __ ] you
know but anyways I was it was in the
shop like five days and in those five
days it felt like I was 16 again you
know before you get your license and you
bum and rides up everybody just kept
thinking man I got to get my [ __ ] car
he's filling all the Petach and [ __ ]
well I got it out and I drove it home
was a big stupid grin on my face I may
have ran an errand or two I don't know
all I know is I took it home sat down
and a beer and I put on the Astros game
I was in a freaking great mood it sounds
like it got their beer commercial this
is great right guys life's going awesome
and what then what happens all of a
sudden his girlfriend said I need to go
to the store and then annoying toner
first so like a dumbass I let her go I
get a call from her 15 minutes later
she's calling me from the side of the
road by an ambulance she had gotten a
wreck I love southern people she got in
a wreck not just a wreck she [ __ ]
totaled the front passenger side of the
car what makes it worse is that it was
her [ __ ] fault god damn it I was
pissed I was honestly going to ask her
if the car was okay first but I knew
that would cause a huge argument when
she got home oh my god isn't that the
worst and you know she was just crying a
[ __ ] I thought wasn't she just them
just to make you feel like a bully if
you actually went you stupid [ __ ] I
just got that [ __ ] thing sticks I
hope you went through the windshield you
know he did actually justified in saying
that what you can so anyways those are
three three great stories
with a person with the car was the
victim and then you get to this last one
I like this last one I've had my 99 BMW
325i just got some work done on the
engine and it runs like new last month
on a Thursday a little tipsy which means
he was shit-faced I got into my car
angry at this girl I had been talking to
okay did she have bruises on her wrists
he's angry did is girly been talking to
it backs up furiously in this parking
garage smacked a larger-than-life pickup
truck which crushes his entire passenger
side taillight and puts a large dent
right underneath it no one's around I
leave a note on the car to give me a
call there's not much damage to the huge
Dodge Ram which means that we've been
parked in the middle of the aisle I
don't want to be a dick but that truck
wasn't moving and you said it was larger
than life and you also mentioned that
you were a little tipsy and you were
angry at this girl this is a horrible
way to tell this story if you wanted
some sort of empathy but you know what
the fact that you brought the broad into
the story I actually actually filled a
few why are we a little tipsy huh were
you buying her drinks all night you know
I want to hear the rest of the story you
got it you got to email me as to why you
were mad at this girl from because I
have to know the back story for me to
actually feel bad that you slammed your
BMW into a goddamn Dodge Ram jag you
know what it sucks I've been there I've
been there something put my truck into a
goddamn ditch one time drunk pissed off
at somebody but anyways thanks for all
the questions thanks for all the all the
stories bunch of cars please come and
see me at The Improv in Pittsburgh next
month and July 10th to 13th and go to LA
bill burr calm for all the dates and one
special side note I'm actually just
found out right before I did this
podcast that George Carlin had passed
away last night thread out here in Santa
Monica
and I didn't really feel like talking
about it to be honest with you because
it's too too [ __ ] depressing all I
can say about the guys he's just you
know he's unbelievable and kinda sad I
don't really want to talk it's 15 all
the guy the guy got fired in 2001 I was
always like a big thing for me the fact
that the guy was in his 60s and he could
still say [ __ ] back he got him fired in
Las Vegas and you know I mean most
people run out of steam by the time this
[ __ ] my age and that guy you know 25
years later still was still freaking
people out but uh I mean I'll need to
tell you guys this but just without a
doubt without a doubt easily top three
of all time I put him right there at
prior prior Carlin and in Lenny Bruce
and [ __ ] brutal [ __ ] brutal awful
way to see these PI didn't bring it up
wanna bring out I try to give you guys
laughs on the [ __ ] rather than talk
about so he was one of the one of the
two reasons I got into this [ __ ] were
him in the Richard Pryor and I used to
do my paper route doing his bit
delivering papers pretending out with
him on stage in front of my kids I went
to school with that's how much I loved
his stuff that's how much the guy meant
to me and you know rest in peace and I
know he didn't believe in an afterlife
so I don't know enjoy your time in the
ground George and thanks for all the
left all right everybody thankful to the
podcast and please keep the questions
coming if anybody knows how to [ __ ] I'm
supposed to hang up these goddamn rings
please let me know and that's it
everybody have a good week all right
[Music]
you all know leading to the fact ya
akhul entertain on the side of the ask
them talk my squadron
by the way split ring you like your
random combat peaceful talk about the
water broke down watch a lot of lows
down and give too much and Facebook the
gallery and
[Music]
like the faint on the side of the yeah
something like the pots out of thumbs on
the [ __ ] done bringing like changing
look like a fancy cup talkin on the
water broke down
what's a lot of love now now they don't
don't they andante andante andante
andante andante andante andante andante
andante understand that
watch the water low sound and on demand
like the one alone now watch the water
broke down watch the water broke down
watch the water broke down watch the
water roll down
[Music]